es ist eine wahre höllenmaschine der
stärkste röntgenlaser der welt heißt
european xfel steht in hamburg und hat
1,2 milliarden euro kostet nach acht
jahren bauzeit geht er jetzt in die
heiße phase mit hilfe von ultra kurzen
laserlicht blitzen im röntgenbereich
ermöglicht der internationalen
forschungsteams ein bislang
unvorstellbaren blick in die nanowelt
wir genau funktioniert welche
mysteriöse dinge sichtbar machen wird
und alles was er sonst noch zum
stärksten leser der welt wissen müsst
jetzt in kriegs und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
das ist der european xfel die abkürzung
steht für x-ray free electron laser
also auf deutsch in etwa röntgenlicht
freie elektronen laser mit hilfe von
ultraschnellen röntgen blitzen soll in
der anlage das sichtbar gemacht werden
was bislang im verborgenen blieb eines
der ersten experimente beispielsweise
dreht sich um proteinstrukturen auch das
filmen von chemischen prozessen ist
geplant beteiligt sind zum beispiel
forschungsteams von deutschen elektronen
synchrotron desy in hamburg stolze 12
milliarden euro hat die anlage gekostet
sie befindet sich zum größten teil
unter der erde
der laser tunnel ist 3,4 kilometer lang
und führt vom desy in hamburg
bahrenfeld nach schenefeld in schleswig
holstein beteiligt sind elf europäische
länder zu fast 60 prozent wird es von
deutschland finanziert dahinter folgt
mit knapp 30 prozent russland
bundesforschungsministerin johanna wanka
hat den röntgenlaser als eine weltweit
einzigartige anlage der spitzenforschung
bezeichnet so funktioniert der
röntgenlaser european xfel es ist ein
bisschen wie beim arzt haut muskeln und
fett verhindern die diagnose ob das bein
gebrochen ist oder die rippe und so
weiter und so fort auch der
röntgenlaser european xfel soll dinge
sichtbar machen die uns bisher verborgen
geblieben sind der funktioniert
allerdings wie eine überdimensionale
lupe oder ein mega mikroskop dies bisher
noch nicht da gewesen ist um das
möglich zu machen sorgt zunächst ein
teilchenbeschleuniger dafür dass
elektronen wolken aus einem stück
metall herausgelöst und beschleunigt
werden
auf einer strecke von zwei kilometern
erreichen sie dann fast
lichtgeschwindigkeit die elektronen
worten sind also unvorstellbar schnell
und energiereich spezielle magnete
bringen sie dann in einen zick-zack-kurs
so dass die elektronen licht abstrahlen
das licht ist schneller als die
elektronen und überholt sie deswegen
dadurch werden einige elektronen
abgebremst und langsamer andere werden
schneller ändern ihre bewegungsrichtung
es bilden sich gruppen beziehungsweise
scheiben die alle im gleichen takt
strahlen die so entstehende
röntgenstrahlung wird durch die
wechselwirkung mit den elektronen immer
stärker röntgenblitze
unglaubliche 27.000 intensiveren blitze
pro sekunde sollen im european xfel
entstehen sie sind unfassbar kurz dauern
weniger als 100 millisekunden und haben
eine wellenlänge von bis zu einem
zehntel nanometer also so viel wie etwa
der abstand zwischen zwei atomen in
einem molekül und das ist genau der
punkt mit diesen blitzen können jetzt
unglaublich kleine strukturen moleküle
zum beispiel beobachtet werden nur um
das unglaubliche daran nochmals zu
verdeutlichen berechnet man die blitze
auf einem quadratzentimeter fläche sind
sie zehn trilliarden mal intensiver also
sonnenlicht ich absolut unvorstellbar
diese röntgenblitze werden dann auf
verschiedene instrumente geleitet an
denen experimente durchgeführt werden
das wird mit dem european xfel erforscht
zusammengefasst können forschungsteams
mit dem konnten leser all diejenigen
winzigen dinge messen und analysieren
die bislang als nicht messbar galten
zudem können super schnelle prozesse
und extreme zustände erforscht werden
spannend also für viele verschiedene
wissenschaftsgebiete unter anderem für
die chemie physik biologie astronomie
insgesamt stehen sechs instrumente zur
verfügung an denen internationale
forschungsteams experimentieren können
biologinnen und biologen zum beispiel
können so molekülstrukturen
herausfinden
der röntgenlaser macht das unmögliche
möglich brauchten forschungsteams
bislang moleküle in ihrer kristallinen
form um ihre atom zusammensetzung zu
entschlüsseln ist dies durch den
european xfel auch so möglich entweder
durch sehr kleine qualitativ
minderwertige kristalle und manchmal
braucht es noch nicht mal die um eine
molekülstruktur zu offenbaren
langfristig könnten diese experimente
dann natürlich auch über die
grundlagenforschung hinaus gehen denn
durch die aufklärung von protein
molekülstrukturen beispielsweise lassen
sich neue arzneimittel entwickeln die
forscherinnen und forscher denken zum
beispiel ganz konkret an neue
schmerzmittel oder mittel die
antibiotikaresistenzen überwinden
könnten auch im bereich der chemie
leistet der leser sensationelles mit ihm
lassen sich bislang nicht messbare
chemische reaktionen entschlüsseln
beispiel chemieunterricht manche
chemische reaktion kennt man aus dem
unterricht ist so kommt
lex dass die moleküle so schnell von
einer zwischenstufe in den nächsten
übergehen dass dies von konventionellen
detektoren bislang nicht messbarer oder
physik die intensiven röntgenstrahlen
machen es tatsächlich möglich atome zu
ionisieren ihnen also ein teil der
elektronen wegzuschießen so lässt sich
unter anderem erforschen wie sich
materie in der sonnenatmosphäre
verhält oder aber auch die
eigenschaften von plasma das eigentlich
nur so kurz stabil ist dass seine
analyse bislang fast unmöglich erschien
ihr seht also das sind also wirklich
super viel versprechen der experimente
hierbei pixum halte ich euch natürlich
auf dem laufenden
zu den versuchen im xl wenn ihr kein
video dazu und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit
elektromagnetische schwarzes loch im
labor erzeugt da sind einem atom mit
einem neunten leser 450 von 62
elektronen weggeschossen worden
elektromagnetische hatte sich dann wie
ein schwarzes loch verhalten also nicht
verpassen und draufklicken viel spaß
dabei und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran